so this Twitter account has become for
better and worse maybe the most
important communications channel for
this particular administration and the
president has blocked some people from
the account because they have criticized
him on Twitter so they respond to his
tweets with criticism either of him or
his policies and the president blocks
them in response and the argument that
we made in the lower court is that the
Twitter account is a public forum under
the First Amendment while the government
can exclude people from that forum for
many different reasons it can't exclude
them simply because they've criticized
the government or criticized government
policies I think what's really important
about the cases that we're litigating
right now the night Institute case
against President Trump and the case of
Davison versus Randall which was decided
by the Fourth Circuit this year is that
they illustrate that as public officials
ranging from the President of the United
States to your local County chairwoman
that as they increasingly use social
media that the First Amendment rules of
the road which have been well
established by the Supreme Court apply
equally to these new kinds of virtual
town halls such as Facebook and Twitter
accounts run by public officials one of
the really gratifying things about the
victory we want in the district court is
that we have seen that victory now cited
dozens of times in other contexts by
individuals who have been blocked by
other public officials but many of these
cases in which individuals have been
able to complain to their public
officials about this kind of
viewpoint-based blocking citing the
victory that we want in this case in the
district court it's very gratifying to
see other people starting to use that
victory in those other contexts